el ejército ruso utiliza la última
tecnología militar francesa en ucrania
si según el medio de investigación
online this close que divulgó una
investigación según la cual francia ha
suministrado armas discretamente al
ejército ruso entre 2015 y 2020 para
modernizar sus tropas de tierra y aire
pese a que en agosto de 2014 con el
inicio de la guerra en el donbass la
unión europea impuso un embargo de armas
desde y hacia rusia según el medio de
comunicación francia aprovechó un vacío
legal como el embargo no es retroactivo
los gobiernos de françois hollande y
manuel mccomb han optado por mantener
estos suministros vinculados a contratos
firmados antes de la aplicación de estas
sanciones
francia ha permitido la ejecución de
determinados contratos firmados desde
2014 en virtud de la llamada cláusula
del abuelo un contrato firmado antes de
la anexión de crimea puede completarse y
las entregas de equipos adquiridos antes
de julio de 2014 pueden continuar
2015 parís ha expedido 76 licencias de
exportación de material bélico a rusia
por un importe total de 152 millones de
euros estos contratos benefician
principalmente a las empresas tal y
safran de las que el estado francés es
el principal accionista no hay armas
letales pero si equipos de alta
tecnología
incluyendo cámaras térmicas para equipar
a más de 1000 tanques rusos sistemas de
navegación y detectores de infrarrojos
para los aviones y helicópteros de
combate de la fuerza aérea rusa
en la actualidad de estos equipos
instalados en helicópteros y tanques
pueden utilizarse en el conflicto de
ucrania contra la población civil
y el ministerio de la armada se defendió
asegurando ser transparente según su
portavoz no se han firmado nuevos
contratos con rusia desde 2014 y no se
han realizado entregas desde el inicio
de la guerra con ucrania